once seen as jeremy corbyn's heir
apparent Rebecca long Bailey was a late
entrant into the Labour leadership race
I've invited everyone here today because
as you might have heard I'm standing to
become the leader of the Labour Party
for her first campaign visit she went to
newcastle-under-lyme and labour held
constituency for nearly a century lost
to the Tories in last month's general
election her aim to find out what went
wrong
certainly brexit was a huge issue we
weren't trusted on brexit thought we
were trying to overturn the referendum
result and I've come for my solution
failed to convince many of our remain
unli voters Labour's candidate here also
blames brexit for his defeat I was
selected on a Friday night when outdoor
knocking on the Saturday morning and
straightaway found labour voters
lifelong labour voters who said they
were not going to vote for us this time
some of them even saying they might vote
Tory for the first time because of
brexit but in the town voters said mr
corbyn was a problem for labour I really
did not like hoping those down the
working money Lowe's down my dad was a
die hard labour all his life but Corbin
this time he danced as a gnome not vote
to him safety first time for news live
Jeremy Corbyn didn't think much of him
didn't think he could run the country
very well so I just went for the best
option is regarding the country and
safety the country really Muslim Bailey
in the front-runner circus Tama have
already secured the 22 nominations from
MPs required to reach the next stage of
the contest so Kier has 68 Jess Phillips
22 sir Kier has 68 just Phillips 22
Clive Lewis only for emily Thorne Bri
just ten Lisa Nandi 24 and Muslim Bailey
26 launching his campaign in Manchester
the Pro remains sakir failed to mention
brexit in his speech instead he spoke of
the need for party unity
not going to trash the last Labour
government but nor are we going to trash
the last four years there have been very
many important move Jeremy Corbyn made
our party the party of anti austerity
and he was right to do so mr. Corbyn
meanwhile attending an anti-war rally
reacted angrily to Emily Thornbury
giving him naught out of 10 for winning
elections I regrets the comments that
some colleagues made who themselves
supported the election manifesto
supported the election campaign and I
think all of us have a responsibility to
take our party forward many Labour MPs
want sakir to take the party forward but
Muslim Bailey will hope that she's to
the taste of party members John Craig
Sky News